en todos esos derechos sociales lo que
llama la atención es el énfasis que está
colocando el presidente en los diálogos
ciudadanos en la participación ciudadana
y en el hecho de que efectivamente haya
una en un proceso de consulta permanente
para poder llegar al congreso y pedir
que se apruebe justamente en los
proyectos de ley asociado a todo eso por
lo pronto en lo que se refiere a
pensiones él está en la idea de por qué
en una pensión básica garantizada al
final de su periodo que estaría como
sigue aproximadamente en 350 dólares
aproximadamente unos 150 mil pesos que
no sean a mikel y eso es
interesante pero eso hay que financiarlo
y financiamiento tiene que ver con la
reforma estructural de ese tema de
pensiones donde aseguró y dejó muy claro
de que el ahorro individual que cada
quien no tiene no va a ser tocado ni va
a ser apropiado ni va a tener ninguna
ninguna modificación pero también dejó
entrever de que el próximo sistema va a
tener un avance solidaria muy potente se
va a mantener algo de este ahorro
individual para las pensiones pero se va
a garantizar que todos tengan una
pensión que sea efectivamente
efectivamente digna por lo tanto va a
haber cambio el sistema de habituales
cuando canción actualmente existente
probablemente modificaciones web o
transformaciones relevantes pero se va a
mantener un proceso de capitales
individual y lo propio con lo que una
reforma integral del sistema de salud
donde efectivamente anda cuenta de la
necesidad que es pueda avanzar no
solamente en la lista de espera
sino que generando ya es centros que
puedan y vamos a hacer de de núcleos
para poder superar ahorita de espera en
varias regiones del país va a empezar
con dos se va a ampliar a siete de
transforma que las y llegar a un nivel
donde la cirugía oncológica no tienen
sepan resolver en menos de 90 días y la
cirugía mayores también rápidamente y
eso más tanto en este minuto lo que era
el presidente de que hay cirugías que
tienen un analista espera un tiempo de
espera superior a 600 días claramente no
impacta y en ese en ese sentido también
lo otro es que ésta afecta a la idea de
salud mental y es muy interesante
no solamente colocar los centros que ha
comprometido en términos de preocuparse
de ir sino también ese foco en la salud
mental en los niños de 34 años a niños
probablemente va a ser un elemento que
va a tener un impacto muy positivo por
diversas razones que el propio
presidente ha dicho algunas de ellas
pero que a nivel de cohesión social sin
lugar a duda base de base importante y
lo propio también los refiere a
viviendas hay en el hecho de pueda
avanzar de las 17 viviendas
con los planes concretos en términos de
uso de terrenos fiscales el terminar los
campamentos pero siendo muy claro y
transparente y ahí está la empático
también en términos decir que vamos el
déficit de vivienda se mantiene desde
600 mil viviendas
nosotros no podemos superar todo eso
pero si podemos hacer algo que alguien
lo que está ofreciendo ahora en su
discurso